[Music]
hey all this is a comprehensive paper
review of the paper on blip this is a
model and a technique for bootstrapping
one's own data set in vision and
language pre-training which is pretty
cool so the video is a comprehensive
review we'll dive into the paper we'll
see what the paper is about i'll explain
you what's in it and by the end of the
video you should have a good
understanding of what's in the paper in
the next video which i'm going to
release tomorrow there's going to be an
interview with the authors of the paper
so also be sure to check that out
because that answers a few very very
interesting questions that i had while
reading the paper itself so i wish you a
lot of fun let me know what you think in
the comments and i'll see you around bye
bye
hey there this video is sponsored by
zetta alpha which is a new neural
discovery and recommendation engine for
papers yes for scientific papers for
trends in research and code in ai their
goal is to become your research
assistant and streamline how you
organize share and stay up to date on
the latest r d this is really cool
because the flood of papers in machine
learning is sheer overwhelming in recent
months zetta alpha uses neural embedding
based search and can give you the best
recommendation of research that matches
your interest and that you don't want to
miss and what better way than to just
try it out so first i start off
searching for today's paper which is the
blip paper and this is really cool
because not only do i get the paper i
also get the github code implementation
and i can directly see the impact on
social media that this paper has this is
much better than something like google
scholar which would just give me a few
links to the paper itself i can now save
this paper under a tagging category that
i'm just gonna invent right now and i
can use zetta alpha to find similar
research here i'm gonna limit my search
to the last three months so i make sure
that i don't miss anything that has
recently been going on that i should
know about when reviewing this paper now
i also like a bunch of those other
papers so i'm gonna save them as well to
the same category once i have a bunch of
papers in my category i can use again
zetta alpha's recommendation engine to
give me more suggested papers to add to
the same category based on what i have
already in there and i can also share
this entire category with my teammates
because everything zeta alpha does is
not only for individuals but also for
teams this is really powerful and can
dramatically accelerate your discovery
of new and relevant research now this
doesn't only work for categories that
you define once you interact with the
search engine z2 alpha is gonna be able
to give you a list a feed of
recommendations from archive from
conferences from blogs from github and
much more this saves you a ton of time
and lets you stay up to date with
whatever is happening if you're at all
into ml research this is hyper relevant
for you and i definitely invite you to
check it out now they do have a free
tier but i got you a great deal if you
go over there right now and use code
yannick you'll get 20 off a personal
assistant subscription again go to zetta
dash alpha.com use kodianik for 20
off right now thanks again so much to
zeta alpha for sponsoring today's video
and now let's get into it see ya
[Music]
hello there today we'll look at blip
bootstrapping language image
pre-training for unified vision language
understanding and generation by jinan li
deng xi li timing xiong stephen hoy
yeah that's it of salesforce research so
this paper proposes two things one is a
new architecture and i want to say
a new conglomeration of existing things
so an arrangement of modules for
multi-task pre-training
this model will take in an image text
pair and perform multiple tasks on it it
has multiple losses and therefore ends
up being able to do multiple things now
that being said this is a pre-training
method so the idea is that for any of
these modules you'll take them you
recompose them downstream
and you fine-tune them on a task
although they do have some
zero-shot results so this is one thing
and this could be really cool if this
alone
turns out to be successful because it
leads the path to a future where we have
much more dynamic compositions of models
and where we would pre-train these
models with a lot of different tasks in
in one thing rather than pre-training
them on just a single task like language
modeling
the other thing is a bootstrapping
method for the data and these two things
are not necessarily disconnected
although i do lament the fact that it's
two things in one paper a little bit but
there's a bootstrapping method for these
image text data set
that includes training captioners and
filters which means that this there's a
part
that learns to synthetically generate
data and then there is a part that
learns to distinguish good from bad data
and that allows them to collect lots and
lots of data from the internet and
filter out bad
badly poorly labeled images which there
exists a lot on the internet and also
allows them to augment the data set by
labeling images themselves so this is
also really interesting and it feeds
really well back into their model
because their model is uniquely capable
of doing this being the multi-task model
that it is so we're going to go through
the architecture through the dataset
bootstrapping method and keep in mind
that i think you know if this catches on
uh this could be there could be recipes
in here for future research that leads
us to a much more dynamic world where we
compose these modules much like we
compose different modules low level
modules and deep learning we could
compose these higher level modules and
losses and
do lots more multi-task pre-training
maybe even dynamically configured but
let's dive in
so
vision language pre-training they say
has recently recently been you know the
the hit
for example if you think of something
like clip i mean that's not even
pre-training but there are lots of
architectures that do vision language
pre-training meaning they take pairs of
images and text so you'll have like some
sort of an image and you'll have like
some sort of text that goes with it
and you'll try to come up with a system
that connects the two in any way they
say the major the existing methods have
two major limitations so
first of all
the
what they call the model perspective
they say they are either the existing
methods are either encoder based or an
encoder decoder architecture so in an
encoder based setup what you would do is
you would take in both of these things
and you would try to come up with
probably a number that represents how
well they fit together so are they good
together or not this is the clip
architecture essentially
so in encoder based models they
criticize that
encoder base are less straightforward to
directly transfer to text generation
tasks so it's not it's not simple to
take clip and actually make it produce
something remember if we have to if you
have to produce an actual image with
clip uh we need to do this diffusion
clip guided diffusion or clip guided
gans vq gans so it's really cumbersome
to make clip generate an image and it's
probably even more cumbersome to make it
generate text because it's not trained
on that so they criticize on these
methods it's not easy to make them do
generation tasks
whereas encoder decoder models have not
been successfully adopted for image text
retrieval tasks so an encoder decoder
model is where you would take the image
probably
and then make the produce the text so
you train it as a language model to auto
regressively produce the caption and
that's really neat for producing
captions but you cannot necessarily do
this task up here very easily with such
a model
you will you will be able to do some
things but they're not necessarily
successful because the task is really a
different task
so
both
both approaches for doing this currently
are not ideal
the other thing is the data perspective
they criticize that these models are
pre-trained on image text pairs that are
essentially scraped from the internet so
collected from the internet
and they say noisy web text is
sub-optimal for vision language learning
we've known for a long time that
there is a trade-off between scale of
data and quality of data and ideally
you'd have both if however if you scrape
from the internet so let's say
you scrape websites and there is like
some text and there is an image
somewhere and the image will have alt
text and that's what's usually used as
the label in these systems so if you
don't know in the html if you have an
image tag that's how that's how the
browser knows it's an image you have the
image tag you have the source attribute
which leads it's it's a url usually that
leads to the image but then you also
have an alt attribute and um
it's really recommended that you put an
alt uh an alt property to the point
where frameworks and linters and so on
they will yell at you if you don't have
it so what does this do um this
specifically is for visually impaired
people for screen readers but also for
bots to know what is in the image so you
put a description there however
a lot of people don't do that um and i
think it makes it actually worse that
linters and so on almost require you to
do it because if you don't want to do it
you're just gonna put like some some
dumb stuff there like image
or people do lots of search engine
optimizations in there so since you know
the search engines don't usually look at
the image itself but at the old text
they try to come up with buzzword-y
things uh so that it's ranked high in
search results so not necessarily the
best quality data
and um their bootstrapping their
bootstrapping method right here
is
is helping in that of getting higher
quality data out of the internet
so how do they do this the first thing
they propose is this model the
multi-modal mixture of encoder decoder
they say it can operate either as a
unimodal encoder or an image grounded
text the
encoder or an image grounded text
decoder
so
yeah we're gonna look at these things
but i think here they say can operate
either as one or this or that uh it's
not like this it's not like the exact
same model can do this it's just that
they they put all of these models into
one big model and then they just use the
part of the model that does the
particular thing so it's not necessarily
super duper unified is what i wanted to
say
um yeah they train the three
the three subparts of their models with
three objectives which we're also going
to look at the second part is this
captioning and filtering
this is what this is what boosts the
data set quality
they say they learn from noisy image
text pairs
by cleaning them by producing more and
cleaning them they train a captioner
which
whose goal is to produce synthetic
captions given web images and a filter
to remove noisy captions from both the
original web text and the synthetic text
so the captioner
will get images produce labels for these
images or produce alt text and then the
filter goes over both the generated ones
and the collected ones and just filters
out everything that it deems to be
qualitatively low standard of course
this needs to be trained on a high
quality data set but these sort of
bootstrapping methods we've seen a
number of times in the recent past that
they actually work in fact this model
this paper here seems to be a good um
accumulation of sort of recognitions and
good practices over the last few years
and we're going to point those out as we
go through
there they're contributions uh here they
say we show that the captioner and the
filter work together to achieve
substantial performance improvement
which
okay i don't know what substantial means
in these kinds of tasks but it's
i it's an improvement they are they
achieve state-of-the-art performance in
a wide range of vision language tasks
and interestingly also uh this is a
property of maybe synthetic data
generation they show more diverse
captions yield larger gains this might
also be a good lesson for people who
want to go
and
apply these methods
lastly they say
next to having state of the art in
downstream fine-tuned tasks they also
achieve zero shot performance uh when
directly transferring
our models to two video language tasks
so never
they they were never trained on video
language tasks never pre-trained never
fine-tuned yet still they have a good
zero shot performance which is okay like
if you understand images then there are
gonna be some video tasks that are your
that you're particularly good at right
um
so
let's dive into the model and i've
already shown you a diagram of the model
they quickly go through this here they
have three parts they have actually
well i want to say four parts to their
model
one part one is a visual transformer a
vit as the image encoder so again they
take an image and they take a piece of
text and now they do stuff with it and
the first part is they encode the image
using a visual transformer that's all
they do with the image they encode it
using evit
with the text they do three
three different things
the first thing is they also just encode
the text unimodally so put the text
through an encoder
and that
with those two things already they've
essentially reproduced clip
except they say it's the same as bert um
yeah
so they've reproduced clip with those
two things because now they can set it
up this visual transformer
and the unimodal encoder they can set it
up as a
similarity
metric so the unimodal encoder will give
you some vector in an embedding space
the visual transformer will give you
some vector in an embedding space you
can set up a contrastive loss
to check whether these two things go
together and whether they are apart from
let's say um any other encoded image or
text
you can do this via contrastive learning
you can do it via regularized methods um
but essentially this is what we've come
to known as encoder only models
the second thing they have is this
image grounded text encoder so the image
grounded text encoder
does almost the same thing as the
unimodal text encoder however it doesn't
encode the text separately it jointly um
it encodes the text while incorporating
attention into the visual transformer
we're gonna see how that goes in a
second but essentially it produces a
vector let's say this one and
while producing that on the path as it
produces that it incorporates
information from the visual transformer
so it will this here is the
output of the visual transformer it will
incorporate that
at multiple layers here via cross
attention into the process so this here
is really a joint kind of encoding of
the text
given the image that's why it's called
image grounded text encoder
what this can do is you can build a
classifier on top of this like a binary
classifier because it is a
representation of the text that has but
that has already
uh the information of the image inside
of it so it's kind of a joint
representation of the image and the text
so you can build a classifier uh for
example whether or not the two things go
together again but you don't have to use
a contrastive loss you can in fact use a
supervised loss and classify
and build a classifier the third thing
is this image grounded text decoder now
again being image grounded that is a
that is a long what is going on
something's up here
there's an image grounded text decoder
the image grounded text decoder is much
like the image grounded text encoder in
that it incorporates cell across
attention however it's a text decoder so
what it will do is it will actually
produce text so it will auto
aggressively produce the text while
incorporating again
information via cross attention from the
visual representation
you can see that they have a different
section on the pre-training objectives
these just map to these three parts so
there's the image text contrastive loss
which is the loss for the first part
there is the image
the image text matching loss which is
the loss for the second part and again
this is just a binary classification
task where the model uses a linear layer
head what they call it an itm an image
text text matching head but it's a
linear layer
to predict whether an image text pair is
positive
which means matched or negative
unmatched given their multi-modal
feature
the the special thing here is they do
have a hard negative mining strategy so
they go to the top part here they go to
the
uh
joint no sir to the disjoint encoding to
this part and they look which ones are
the hard negatives which means that
uh
negatives that have a high contrastive
similarity and they use those
specifically to train this loss here
the last loss is a language modeling
loss
which is
obviously relevant for the third part
this is a cross-entropy loss it
maximizes the likelihood of the text in
an auto-regressive manner
if we put all of this together we get
this model right here
again if we go through it the input data
are two things the input data are the
image down here and the piece of text
here again we know these go together
because we've scraped them from the web
so these two we know they're go they go
together this is not an unsupervised
training this is essentially supervised
learning
for two things that we know go together
the first thing is we gonna encode the
image through the image encoder that's
the image encoder this is the image
representation this is just a vit this
is a visual transformer um
i don't know i don't think they freeze
it but they may start from a checkpoint
all of this is jointly trained so all of
these losses i i as i understand them
are jointly trained
um so then we have the vision
representation what we can do is we can
put the text first of all through the
text encoder you can see we can append
different tokens right here to let the
encoder know what we're currently doing
because we also have some parameter
sharing going on so the text encoder
gets the input text it will also compute
an encoding and then we have this
contrastive loss between the two
encodings they need to be close for
pairs that we know go together
and um they need to be far apart for
other pairs you can do something like in
batch negatives or you can as we said
mine hard negatives from the contrastive
from this part
well that makes no sense you can
mine contrastive so you can mine hard
negatives
for that part over here given this part
over here
which makes me believe okay maybe i
haven't read
closely enough maybe they also just
train one of the losses maybe for each
batch uh because they are they have to
sample differently for the things
um i it doesn't make too much of a
difference whether they train it really
all jointly jointly or always activate
one of the three text pathways
this would be interesting to figure out
yeah
so
the last thing the second thing they do
is they give it to this image grounded
text encoder again this gets the text
and a little token to show what's going
on it will encode and now you can see it
has this cross attention module and the
cross attention module as it encodes it
incorporates information
that comes from all the way over here it
comes all the way over here from the
image so the image representation is
part of the encoding here which means
this thing has information about both
the text and the image
now
um
yeah of course it's still a it's still
it's not symmetric right we don't uh the
joint encoding is asymmetric in the
sense that it is the text that is
encoded based on the image and that
allows them to you to only compute the
image representation once so they only
need to do this pathway on the left here
once and then they can reuse that
representation for all of the for all of
the different paths in the text here
um
yeah you can see that on the left this
is the difference on the left here this
is skipped the cross attention is
skipped
we don't have cross attention is just
an encoding of the text itself and here
it's really a joint encoding
which means that this thing here
contains information on both the image
and the text and we can perform any sort
of task that we want with this joint in
coding in our case we simply train it on
a very similar objective as the
contrastive loss in that it's a binary
classification it needs to figure out
whether or not the two things actually
go together or not
the third thing again almost the same is
this decoder the text decoder same input
except there's a little decode token
there is a difference in that this is
bi-directional the other two modules
have bi-directional self-attention
because they are encoders so they get to
use bi-directionality
here we use causal self-attention which
essentially means that in the text you
only get to attend things so if you
produce a particular token right here
you only get to attend to tokens that
are behind
yourself this is
a bit of a hack
because otherwise we couldn't train
these things with batches or in parallel
um
it is definitely it is definitely
possible to use bi-directional
self-attention as long as you cap as
long as you mask whatever comes next so
you you want to mask sort of the future
but within the past you could totally
use bi-directional self-attention
again this is just a hack to make
training easier but it's become it's
come to be a popular hack so everyone's
doing it
again you can see there's cross
attention coming from the image and here
you can really see that it's necessary
right
if i want to actually
produce text i need some sort of
information of what i want to produce
and so this language modeling loss here
really needs the the cross attention
really needs the input from the image so
again this comes from here
from the image representation so there
you have it it's an unholy concoction of
many different things uh in one
and this is all trained jointly right
and uh yeah
i'm excited about this because i think
not necessarily this particular
arrangement like i have lots of stuff to
criticize or or uh
like lots of choices here that are kind
of arbitrary like why is this why this
asymmetry in you know i have the image
encoded once and i have cross attention
into all the text encoders um
why not the other way around why don't
we do image generation tasks why don't
we do any sort of masked masked modeling
like masked language modeling this could
even be in the image
there's lots of stuff let's say to
criticize but i think what this thing
shows is that
a good recipe for the future could be to
combine lots of these different methods
together combine lots of them into one
big thing
reusing parts intelligently and then
train them jointly we could even think
of frameworks that do this automatically
or that allow you to really easily set
this up with a few lines of code and it
will figure out by itself like the
framework would figure out itself how
what it can compose and how how it could
reuse what you can also see right here
is uh i've over i've overshadowed it a
little bit with my
thing right here but there's color and
the color indicates shared parameters
which is also really interesting so you
can see that essentially the text
encoders aren't three separate encoders
but they're they largely share
parameters for example the feed forward
uh parameters are shared the cross
attention parameters they're all shared
except of course they're not active in
this encoder
the bi-directional self-attention
parameters are shared the causal
self-attention uh those ones are
separate over here but if we had some
sort of other autoregressive
other regressive module
they would be shared too so you share
whatever you could in these
architectures and that reduces the
overhead but also in their evaluations
really helps which
i guess makes sense um
well i don't know if the tasks are too
distant you might get this catastrophic
forgetting
but in their case
it does help
yes which i can i can i could guess
right by for example the the
bi-directional self-attention right here
since these two modules are almost doing
the same task it's
it's
reasonable that they would share
parameters
so we've gone through a whole lot of
things that they say down here
they do reason through their choices a
little bit even though i think i think
these choices they
are either arbitrary or they're guided
by experiments you know just seeing what
works better they do bring up some
hypotheses of what they think you know
why why the things work and why the
things don't work
they say the text encoder and decoder
share all parameters except for the
self-attention layer the reason is that
the differences between the encoding and
decoding tasks are best captured by the
self-attention layers so they're
essentially saying that
whether you want to encode or decode
that is mostly gonna be different in the
attention layers not from the
architectural perspective but um
from sort of the how the task is done
perspective and that i don't i don't
think necessarily you can say this right
like you can't necessarily say the feed
forward layers have a similar job in or
have similar features and perform
similar functions whether you're
encoding or decoding i i don't just
don't think that's
out of the box
really evident uh that would need to be
supported by evidence so yeah
um
but it seems to work well in empirical
evaluations and so i'm going to i'm
going to i'm with them sharing the
parameters but the reasoning are more
hypotheses
so the second part they go into is this
cap filled again this is a bit
disconnected although it plays well into
their model
here they criticize how these data sets
are usually collected
they say alt text often do not
accurately describe the visual content
of the images that are scraped from the
web and that's why they have a
bootstrapping method so what they do
is they collect a dataset from the
internet and um
yeah well i find this diagram here to be
a little bit
complicated uh so we're just gonna make
our own so they they have the internet
i'm gonna this is a globe with you know
the lines and so on so we're gonna
collect a big chunk of data uh of pairs
of images and text
images and all text from the web really
noisy
and what we're going to do with this
stuff is we're going to train a first
blip architecture
or a first no how they call it med
architecture multi something something
whatever their model is on top we're
just going to train that with this noisy
data and that's going to be our first
iteration model now this is really
noisy so far and so on but what we're
going to do then is we're going to
fine-tune this um we're going to
fine-tune a filter and a captioner so
we're going to fine-tune a filter and a
captioner on supervised data
there exists some supervised data sets
um
and one of them i believe is the coco
data set um yes the coco data set so
this step here
we need supervised data and supervised
data of image text pairs so human-made
captions for existing images which uh
it's a sort of a proxy for quality so of
these things we can be sure that the
quality is relatively high
if we could find some sort of an
automated way to get really high quality
image text pair data
it doesn't necessarily need to be human
labeled it just needs to be high in
quality
so they use that to train a filter and a
captioner now what is the filter and the
captioning model
now these are going to be uh fine-tuned
versions of their med models for example
the captioner takes in an image right
and gives you a caption a synthetic
caption now this is something our model
can do if we
you know we just take two parts so we
take this part and we take this part
right here
um
this is now a captioning model
so the idea here the general idea of of
blip of this med model is that we
pre-train all of these things together
and then we sub-select uh or we
rearrange even the different
sub-components and then fine tune them
on a downstream task
and one
easy way is to take two components
simply deactivate all others and let
them run in inference mode so now we
have a captioning model
the captioning the filtering model on
the other hand uh very similar but it
takes an image and a piece of text both
inside and it will output a score of
whether the two things go together or
not now this
of course we can achieve in multiple
ways but we can achieve this
in the probably the most high quality
way by taking the image encoder and
taking this part right here that is
specifically trained to jointly encode
you might ask why don't we use why don't
we use this module right here and then
use this contrastive estimation
we could also do that definitely
but usually
um there are always there are always
multiple ways of determining similarity
you can have sort of the
the two stack encoder so here is the
image and here is the text you can have
separate encoders for them and then at
the end determine whether they go
together and that's usually good if you
want to do something like um
like a search index because you can
pre-compute a lot of these things you
can pre-compute all the embeddings for
the images
and then at inference time if you have a
query using text you want to search an
image via text you only need to encode
the text
whereas with a joint encoding it's
really different you need to you need to
input both into the encoder
and that will give you a score at the
end
and
if you want to build a search engine
like this then for every single time you
issue a query what you need to do is you
need to go through the whole data set
and encode the
query here together with all of the
images get the score for each one and
then evaluate that so you can see there
is a trade-off the left side is way
friendlier computation wise if you have
an existing data set the right side is
qualitatively higher because during
computation through these layers the two
things can already attend to one another
whereas really the only interaction here
is the end
over here
so this is qualitatively better estimate
of um
of whether the two things match or don't
match
and that's where we that's why we're
going to
to
take to have the filter here
since we're working since we're
filtering the data set we can jointly
encode the two things anyway so we're
going to fine tune that part to pre to
become our filter so now we have a
fine-tuned part one captioner one filter
what can we do now well we can take our
data set
this thing right here and we can use the
captioner to produce another data set by
just taking the images so we just take
the images here we put them through the
captioner and we get another data set so
we get another data set it has it's
going to have the same images right but
it's going to have different text so i'm
going to put this so this is a
synthetic data set we can then join the
two data sets together
so join the two day the sets
and then we can put them both through
the filter so
i'm going to put them both through the
filter and the filter will simply
filter out any image text pair that is
not adequate which means that
it will filter out any image text pair
which doesn't match well together given
the fine tuning of the filter on the on
the supervised or high quality data set
so then we end up with a data set of and
we can restrict it like to only have one
caption for each image or something like
this and we end up with a data set of
image text pairs which is large because
we've augmented it with synthetic data
but also is of high quality because we
have done the filtering
now that
all of this being said again this highly
relies on the quality of the data set
that we fine-tune on and of the
diversity of that data set as well
because you can also imagine if that
data set isn't um
containing much of the domain that
you're looking at then your filter will
learn to essentially down rank
everything because it says well uh my
data set says these two things don't go
well together because i actually have
just no data in that region so there's a
bit of danger in doing this uh you
really need to pay attention at what
data set you're fine-tuning but this is
how you bootstrap a good data set so you
can see go from here to here and you can
think of multiple things again i think
this paper is less about the particular
method they choose um and i think more
about
you know what could be recipes for the
future and i think
in the recent times we've seen a lot of
synthetic data generation first of all
being really helpful we've seen this in
a number of reinforcement learning
applications um a number of even nlp
applications so synthetic data is really
really uh
picking up i want to say
with advances in sim to real and so on
and then also this this approach of
filtering
this has come up more and more in recent
years where generative models are paired
with discriminative models that either
re-rank their outputs or filter their
outputs for quality this seems to be a
very good recipe
for achieving for achieving generative
tasks in general
not only train a generator but train a
ranker or filter on top of that it's
pretty computationally efficient it's
easy to implement and uh yeah i think
it's a good recipe for the future
and one can think of various ways here
to improve this like to multi mult to do
this bootstrapping multiple times um
yeah
to to uh collect this supervised data
set in a different manner and so on i
think this there's a lot of
possibilities here that are not uh yet
explored uh which i find to be pretty
pretty cool
so that's essentially
all
yeah okay no i was actually wrong here
you can see the filter is actually
fine-tuned
on both of the objectives to learn
whether text matches the image
so this it's both the contrastive and
the uh the single classifier loss
although i do think
um
i do think the filter
like what they actually pay attention to
at the end is going to be this thing
right here is going to be uh the
classification head
but i i guess it doesn't hurt to use
both losses as you fine tune it
and since all parameters are shared
essentially
you really don't have
you really don't have you can like it's
it's easy to try and it's not too much
of an overhead so that's the methods
again they have this uh concoction of
modules that they all pre-train jointly
with their respective losses and then on
the other hand they have
this bootstrapping method
where they can directly use their model
right that's the way these integrate
these two
since they have a model that can do all
of these different things they can
fine-tune that model to become a filter
or to become a captioner and the same
thing holds for the results downstream
um
here they have some examples by the way
of generated and
so the bottom text is always a generated
one
the top text is one from the data set
anything that's red is filtered out by
the filter
anything that's
green is accepted by the filter
yeah so they
they also discuss a little bit of the
dangers of doing this of training the
filtering and the captioning uh on the
from the same pre-training state on the
same data set which is that
like there is some going to be some
confirmation bias in that
the filter will uprank things that the
captioner produces because they're
essentially
learned from the same data that's why
they don't share perhaps they fine-tune
them separately to combat this a little
bit but i still think that you're going
to have
some of that in there definitely
but you know it's
this is you know
this is a real data
from bridge near my house which might be
true right but it's not very descriptive
and the filter realizes it yet a flock
of birds flying over a lake at sunset
that's pretty descriptive
another interesting thing is that they
use nucleus sampling here which is a
common strategy but they do
find that using nuclear sampling leads
to better performance and that
because it generates more diverse and
surprising captions which contain more
new information that the model could
benefit from
this they compare this to beam search
and beam search essentially goes for the
highest likelihood sample it tends to
generate safe captions that are common
in the data set hence offering less
extra knowledge i think that's also
really cool uh recognition right here
that
um
if we sample things from generative
models we might have different goals and
therefore it might not always be good to
like it might be good to have an
objective or a sampling method that
encourages diversity we've already seen
this in alpha code and my question there
was already a little bit do we even have
the correct training procedures for this
because we train maximum likelihood uh
or do we have the correct sampling
procedures for this
all of these are interesting questions
and i think this kind of research
validates that it's not all the same
like
uh depending on what we want to do
our training and sampling procedures uh
need to adjust i don't want to dive too
deep into the results they are
outperforming other things by some
margin like i don't necessarily agree
that they outperform things so heavily
as they advertise but you know that's
research currently um
again they allude to the fact that they
share parameters here
and why that is
they say sharing all the layers except
for the self attention leads to better
performance compared to not sharing
that's the part i believe right totally
you share numbers go up good
but then they say if the shared
attention layers are shared the model's
performance would degrade to the
conflict between the encoding and the
decoding tasks and this
i think yeah this stuff needs needs
evidence
um
because
i mean yeah i'm fine with just going
with the numbers here you can see the
various ways they combine the things for
example for visual question answering
they first encode the image then they
feed that to the text encoder then they
feed that to the decoder so you can see
you can not only sub select modules but
you can rearrange them right because you
fine tune you can adjust the parameters
so this connection already exists in the
previous model this connection doesn't
so you can sort of rearrange and
recombine these modules uh to do various
things you can see here we have two
image or a double image encoder or i
guess the image encoder get just gets
two samples and then we also have two
one
a duplication of these cross attention
modules and then
we output that into a newly trained
merge layer so this is the exciting part
right here and i feel i feel really i
don't want to necessarily go into this
because we might go into this in the
interview
but
i feel a future where we have frameworks
coding frameworks where this kind of
stuff could be supported in an automatic
fashion where i don't have to you know
go and really hand define exactly how i
want these things combined but i could
have a more high level descriptive
language that allows me to do this whole
pre-training arrangements and this
recombination for downstream fine-tuning
that's really exciting
all right i'm gonna leave it at that i
hope you had a good overview if you want
to dive into the results you know
feel free there's lots of tables in here
it's a really thorough evaluation which
is really cool because it lends a lot of
credence to their methods and with that
let me know what you think in the
comments and bye bye
[Music]